Shure: 为什么写着原浆荞麦啤酒3元一罐
Shure: Why does it say raw buckwheat beer for 3 yuan per can?
Shure: 而打开冰箱却一罐啤酒都没有
Shure: But there's no beer in the fridge.
Shure: 为什么为什么
Shure: Why, why?
Shure: 配上这个音乐就
Shure: With this music...
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha.
Shure: 就忍不住
Shure: I just can't help it.
Shure: 你知道吧
Shure: You know, right?
Shure: 保卫黄河
Shure: Defend the Yellow River.
Shure: 保卫华北
Shure: Defend North China.
Shure: 保卫全中国
Shure: Defend all of China.
Jake:我靠你说
Jake: Damn, you said...
Jake:哈哈哈你把这个12台电脑烧了哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, you burned these 12 computers, hahaha.
Shure: 好多黄油啊
Shure: So much butter.
Jake:一个烟头打过去
Jake: A cigarette butt thrown over.
Shure: 哦一会是不是要吃那什么来着
Shure: Oh, are we gonna eat that later?
Shure: 我把麻将给卸了吧
Shure: I'll take off the Mahjong tiles.
Jake:行啊可以
Jake: Sure, go ahead.
Shure: 好好吧
Shure: Alright, fine.
Shure: 麻酱在哪
Shure: Where's the sesame paste?
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:没灯了没灯没灯了
Jake: No lights, no lights.
Jake:对啊对啊
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:是好
Jake: It's good.
Shure: 家人们
Shure: Guys...
Shure: 麻酱昨天放到哪里了
Shure: Where did we put the sesame paste yesterday?
Shure: 应该不会吧昂
Shure: It shouldn't be, right?
Shure: 啊啊
Shure: Ah, ah.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Shure: 来给家人们表演一个卸麻酱好吧
Shure: Let me show you guys how to take off the sesame paste, okay?
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Okay
Jake:充电宝是吧
Jake: A power bank, right?
Jake:电爆
Jake: Power explosion
Jake:呃这个可以显示
Jake: Uh, this can show
Jake:我有很多电脑
Jake: I have a lot of computers
Jake:我可以下载电脑
Jake: I can download computers
Jake:但是你要先这是一个脆弱的硬盘
Jake: But you have to, this is a fragile hard drive
Jake:对对对你要规范使用它
Jake: Yes, yes, you have to use it properly
Jake:它很脆弱
Jake: It's very fragile
Jake:它很便宜很脆弱
Jake: It's cheap and fragile
Jake:那那个那个充电宝给我
Jake: Give me that power bank
Jake:那几点零了
Jake: What time is it now?
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:你什么专业来着哈哈哈
Jake: What's your major again? Hahaha
Jake:什么专业
Jake: What major?
Jake:麻将专业
Jake: Majong major
Jake:有有的
Jake: There is, there is
Alice:有
这可以直接喝吗
Alice:可以
Jake:开了吗
Jake: Is it on?
Jake:没有开
Jake: It's not on
Jake:变脸了没有开
Jake: Changed face, not on
Jake:你那你就热一个吧
Jake: Heat one up then
Jake:热一个好点
Jake: Heating it is better
Jake:是没电了所以
Jake: It's out of battery, so
Jake:OK OK OK那你过也
Jake: OK OK OK, you go ahead
Jake:对对对你等他
Jake: Yes, yes, wait for him
Jake:呃他应该你
Jake: Uh, he should, you
Jake:你现在店很少
Jake: You have very little battery now
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yes, yes
Jake:店很少可能不能可能冲到10%
Jake: Very little battery, maybe can't even charge to 10%
这有纸吗？
Alice:有
好，谢谢
Jake:想陶喆了
Jake: Missing David Tao
Jake:忍不住了
Jake: Can't hold it
Jake:忍不了了
Jake: Can't hold it anymore
Jake:这个水桶怎么用
Jake: How to use this water bucket?
Alice:按压
Alice: Press it
Jake:嗯那个
Jake: Hmm, that
Jake:还要等吗
Jake: Still waiting?
Shure: 筷子在哪呢
Shure: Where are the chopsticks?
Jake:要插电是吧
Jake: Need to plug in, right?
Jake:那我上楼接水我上去
Jake: Then I'll go upstairs to fetch water, I'm going up
Shure: 这筷子昨天是刷了还是没刷呢
Shure: Were these chopsticks washed yesterday or not?
Jake:不用了我放楼接
Jake: No need, I put them upstairs.
Jake:好好好
Jake: Okay, okay, okay.
Jake:一会他们收拾完房间
Jake: Once they finish cleaning the room,
Jake:然后你们也收拾一下房间
Jake: Then you guys clean up the room as well.
Jake:收拾完之后
Jake: After cleaning,
Jake:有待我们稍微讲一讲你们要干什么
Jake: We need to briefly talk about what you guys will do.
Tasha: 我
Tasha: Me
Jake:一般
Jake: Usually
Tasha: 出什么方案
Tasha: What plan do we come up with?
Jake:没有处罚
Jake: No punishment.
Jake:就是加一些缓解
Jake: Just adding some relief.
Jake:然后吃火锅
Jake: Then we eat hotpot.
Jake:吃完火锅之后把礼物送掉
Jake: After hotpot, we give out the gifts.
Jake:你好着呢
Jake: Are you okay?
Choiszt: 哈哈哈哈
Choiszt: Hahaha
Shure: 是的还有一袋
Shure: Yes, there's one more bag.
Jake:我们还是到二楼吃火锅吧
Jake: Let's go to the second floor to eat hotpot.
Jake:我们上去把桌子给搬中间去
Jake: We'll move the table to the middle.
Jake:一楼确实拿来连鸡蛋都吃不了
Jake: The first floor can't even handle eating eggs.
Jake:还没弄好
Jake: Still not done yet.
Jake:还没穿好
Jake: Still not dressed yet.
Jake:卧槽
Jake: Damn.
Jake:他的
Jake: His.
Jake:哎你我我我
Jake: Hey you, I, I, I
Jake:说帮我拍一张
Jake: Asked you to take a picture for me.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey
Shure: 开什么
Shure: Open what?
Shure: 拍一张是吧
Shure: Take a picture, right?
Jake:好对就这对联机太黑
Jake: Yes, just like this, it's too dark.
Shure: 哦你们三个
Shure: Oh, you three.
Shure: 1414
Jake:v three v three
Jake: v three v three
Jake:呃摆拍
Jake: Uh, pose.
Jake:摆拍一下摆拍
Jake: Pose a bit, pose.
Jake:不要打麻将了
Jake: Don't play mahjong.
Jake:发给老板看了
Jake: Send it to the boss.
Shure: 我们什么时候打麻将
Shure: When are we playing mahjong?
Shure: 对不说有这个环节
Shure: Didn't you say there's this segment?
Jake:那我就这样
Jake: Then I'll just do this.
Jake:作为一个老板
Jake: As a boss
Shure: 你们的严肃的办公吗
Shure: Do you guys work seriously?
Jake:你干活呀
Jake: You should work!
Jake:你这是干嘛呀哈哈哈
Jake: What are you doing? Hahaha
Shure: 你得一边喝着咖啡
Shure: You need to drink coffee
Shure: 然后一边守着手里工作都不停
Shure: And keep working without stopping
Jake:对对对是是是
Jake: Yes, yes, that's right
Shure: 哎谢明珠脸没露出来哎
Shure: Hey, Xie Mingzhu's face didn't show up
Jake:那
Jake: Well
Shure: 对对对好好好
Shure: Yes, yes, good, good
Shure: 然后你在那个帅往右边侧一侧脸
Shure: Then turn your face slightly to the right
Shure: 右右右哎对
Shure: Right, right, yes
Shure: 然后再往后一点
Shure: And a little bit back
Shure: 帅往后一点
Shure: Move back a bit
Shure: 然后再往右一点甩脸往右侧一点OK OK
Shure: Then turn your face to the right a bit more, OK, OK
Jake:就上新闻
Jake: This is for the news
Jake:你莫不也不过这样
Jake: Don't just do it like that
Shure: OK OK OK
Shure: OK, OK, OK
Shure: 无敌
Shure: Invincible
Jake:这这个没没拍群啊
Jake: This, this wasn't filmed in the group
Jake:这个电脑少拍了
Jake: We missed filming some computers
Jake:少拍几台电脑
Jake: Missed a few computers
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah
Shure: 啊懂了懂了
Shure: Ah, got it, got it
Jake:对
Jake: Yes
Shure: 怎么摸鱼呢
Shure: How do you slack off?
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay
Shure: 可以
Shure: Alright
Jake:这个一般是什么创业劲头是吧
Jake: This is usually the entrepreneurial drive, right?
Jake:等到这个市值百亿的时候
Jake: When the market value reaches a billion
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes
Jake:这张照片
Jake: This photo
Shure: 然后就是雷总杨总
Shure: Then it's like CEO Lei and CEO Yang
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yes, yes
Jake:交配一下
Jake: Mate for a bit
Tasha: 啊开始第二波
Tasha: Ah, starting the second wave
Alice:这眼影盘比较贵我舍不得
Alice: This eyeshadow palette is quite expensive, I can't bear to use it
Shure: 所以你没有看到我刚才给你发的视频
Shure: So you didn't see the video I just sent you
Shure: 在放安普
Shure: Playing Anpu
Shure: 我很伤心
Shure: I'm really sad.
Jake:你你的
Jake: You, your...
Jake:可能啊你
Jake: Maybe you...
Jake:你们俩在你们俩在互相传
Jake: You two are just passing things back and forth.
Jake:哦哦哦来来来
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, come on.
Jake:打扫了
Jake: Clean up.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 怎么切我歌呢
Shure: Why did you cut my song?
Katrina:  晶晶
Katrina: Jingjing.
Shure: 哎很伤心
Shure: Hey, very sad.
Shure: 还没满day
Shure: Not even a full day.
Shure: 陪你走到Sunday呢
Shure: I'll walk with you until Sunday.
Jake:哎是丧
Jake: Yeah, it's depressing.
Shure: 可以可以可以
Shure: It's okay, it's okay, it's okay.
Jake:去吧
Jake: Go on.
Jake:可以啊对对
Jake: It's fine, yeah, yeah.
Shure: 好嘞谢谢你
Shure: Alright, thank you.
Jake:对门口有好多垃圾
Jake: There's a lot of trash at the door.
Jake:就门后面
Jake: Just behind the door.
Jake:门后面垃圾是归谁管
Jake: Who's responsible for the trash behind the door?
Jake:这些啊我们纸盒还有机会
Jake: These cardboard boxes, we still have a chance.
Jake:要吗啊挑一挑
Jake: Do you want to sort them out?
Jake:哦哦哦就我我我OK
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, just me, me, me, okay.
Shure: 咱们这有酱油来着吗
Shure: Do we have any soy sauce here?
Alice:酱油没有
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 民宿没自带点什么调料之类的
Shure: Does the guesthouse provide any condiments?
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Alice:啊？
Shure: 民宿没自带点调料什么的
Shure: Does the guesthouse provide any condiments?
Alice:没吧
Alice: I don't think so.
Jake:你好你好你好啊
Jake: Hello, hello, hello.
Shure: 浇什么
Shure: What to pour?
Jake:你在哪啊
Jake: Where are you?
Shure: 水多了放糖
Shure: Add sugar if there's too much water.
Shure: 糖多了放水
Shure: Add water if there's too much sugar.
Shure: 这是哪个rapper啊
Shure: Which rapper is this?
Shure: 叫什么
Shure: What's their name?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 是我问叫什么这个人
Shure: I was asking what this person's name is.
Shure: OK多少粉丝现在
Shure: Okay, how many followers do they have now?
Shure: 网易云呢
Shure: What about on NetEase Cloud?
Shure: 觉得感觉可以买他点歌哎
Shure: I think we can buy his song.
Shure: 我还买过好多比咱们小的
Shure: I've also bought many that are younger than us.
Shure: 破麻酱
Shure: Broken sesame paste.
Shure: 那叫一个地道
Shure: That's really authentic.
Shure: 嘀嗒嘀嘀嗒嘀嗒
Shure: Tick-tock, tick-tock, tick-tock.
Shure: 完了水加多了
Shure: Oh no, added too much water.
Jake:哈哈哈这是为什么
Jake: Hahaha, why is that?
Jake:这么为什么能拍出这种照片是吗
Jake: How can you take such a photo?
Jake:这个很难reason
Jake: This is hard to reason.
Jake:我拍了一个这个
Jake: I took this one.
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Jake:有点厉害
Jake: It's kind of impressive.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Not bad.
Jake:现在可以去了
Jake: We can go now.
Jake:插上电我们对齐就可以去
Jake: Plug it in, align it, and we can go.
Shure: 我卸好麻酱了
Shure: I finished with the sesame paste.
Shure: 但是麻酱是淡的
Shure: But the paste is bland.
Shure: 咱们没有酱油
Shure: We don't have soy sauce.
Jake:试着开机
Jake: Try turning it on.
Jake:怎么做到的
Jake: How did you do it?
Shure: 呃也不是
Shure: Uh, not really.
Shure: 就是买了点彩虹元素
Shure: Just bought some rainbow elements.
Shure: 但是本人并不是的
Shure: But I am not really into it.
Jake:oh
Jake: Oh.
Alice:怎么样
Tasha: 真好看的
Shure: 我要把头发扎起来太长了
Shure: I need to tie up my hair, it's too long.
Tasha: 以假乱真一朵
Tasha: Almost indistinguishable from the real thing.
Tasha: 不会谢掉吧
Tasha: It won't wither, right?
Alice:永不凋谢的花
Jake:火这糖怎么办
Jake: What about this sugar?
Jake:给它融了倒掉是吧
Jake: Melt it and pour it out, right?
Jake:唐人厉害
Jake: The Tang people are impressive.
Shure: 哦这还有两个真好
Shure: Oh, there are two more, great.
Jake:收拾好了
Jake: All cleaned up.
Katrina: 走不走看狗去
Katrina: Are we going to see the dogs?
Katrina: 然后要回来搞搞饭了
Katrina: Then we need to come back and cook.
Shure: 走
Shure: Let's go.
Jake:对去看狗吧
Jake: Yes, let's go see the dogs.
Shure: 走
Shure: Let's go.
Katrina: 他还在吗
Katrina: Is he still there?
Katrina: 他俩去吗
Katrina: Are they going?
Katrina: 你们俩去吗
Katrina: Are you two going?
Katrina: 你俩去吗
Alice:阿姨卫生间收了吗
Alice: Hey, is the bathroom cleaned up?
拉圾我给你收了
Alice:哦，好的，好的
Lucia: 哦对
Lucia: Oh, right.
Lucia: 楼上那个洗手间也换一下可以吗
Lucia: Can you also change the trash bag in the upstairs bathroom?
Lucia: 就是垃圾袋
Lucia: Just the trash bag.
Lucia: 哦好谢谢啊
Lucia: Oh, thanks a lot.
Lucia: 哦也行
Lucia: Oh, that works too.
Jake:洗洗
Jake: Wash it.
Shure: 这箱子我们留着还有点用
Shure: Let's keep this box, it might still be useful.
Jake:谢谢您
Jake: Thank you.
Jake:搁哪呢
Jake: Where is it?
Jake:搁这呢
Jake: It's here.
Lucia: 啊可以的
Lucia: Ah, that's fine.
Lucia: 只要就是主要就是那个垃圾桶
Lucia: As long as the main thing is the trash can.
Lucia: 收拾一下就行了
Lucia: Just tidy it up a bit.
Lucia: 呃这边的这些箱纸箱吗
Lucia: Uh, these cardboard boxes here?
Lucia: 呃这个这个也不要了
Lucia: Uh, we don't need this one either.
Jake:研究完了
Jake: Done with the research?
Jake:研究出了idea
Jake: Did you come up with an idea?
Jake:idea出来了
Jake: Got an idea?
Alice:呃一个比较杂乱的idea
Alice: Uh, it's a bit of a messy idea.
Jake:OK行
Jake: OK, sure.
Lucia: 嗯对那个应该是外卖垃圾
Lucia: Hmm, yeah, that's probably takeout trash.
Jake:那一块可以聊聊
Jake: We can talk about that.
Lucia: 对对对然后这个这个箱子也不要了
Lucia: Yes, yes, and this box can go too.
Katrina: 你知道就是嗯那种
Katrina: You know, like, um, those...
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Katrina: 就是小玩偶然后他可以抱在那个
Katrina: Those little dolls that you can hang on door handles?
Katrina: 就是这种门把手上那个叫什么挂件吗
Katrina: Like those door handle hangers, what are they called?
Lucia: 没看这京东快递
Lucia: Didn't you see the JD package?
Alice:门把手挂件
Alice: Door handle hanger.
Lucia: 这刚拿回来的吗
Lucia: Did you just get this?
Katrina: 就是嗯包括你有一个这样的圆柱子
Katrina: Yeah, and you have this cylinder thing too.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Katrina: 那个东西可以这样抱着他叫什么
Katrina: That thing that can hug it, what's it called?
Alice:那什么啪啪圈什么
Alice: That, um, slap bracelet thing?
Lucia: 这边这些是要用的
Lucia: These things here we still need.
Katrina: 我不知道搜什么关键词哎
Katrina: I don't know what keywords to search for.
Alice:你可以试着搜类似的然后看有没有，然后再找
Alice: You can try searching for something similar and see if it comes up.
Lucia: 呃对这些先别动吧这些我不确定
Lucia: Uh, don't touch these for now, I'm not sure about them.
Alice:啪啪圈试着搜一下
Alice: Try searching for "Papang Circle".
Shure: 哦我前两天看那个
Shure: Oh, I saw that a couple of days ago.
Shure: 一个表情包啪啪屈原的图然然后
Shure: It was a meme with Qu Yuan's picture, and then...
Jake:呃对齐一下
Jake: Uh, align it.
Jake:对齐之后就可以
Jake: Once it's aligned, you can...
Katrina: 就就还有那种可以
Katrina: And also, there's that kind of...
Katrina: 就是你背书包上
Katrina: You know, on your backpack...
Katrina: 他有抱在你书包上的那种
Katrina: It can hug onto your backpack.
Shure: 然后说这
Shure: And then it says...
Katrina: 叫什么挂件
Katrina: What do you call it, a pendant?
Shure: 这是我们小时候玩的最早的SM哈哈哈
Shure: This was our earliest form of SM when we were kids, hahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈够了真的是
Katrina: Hahaha, that's enough, seriously.
Katrina: 走吧你们去不去散散步
Katrina: Shall we go for a walk?
Jake:来对齐对齐
Jake: Come on, align it, align it.
Lucia: 哎咱门口就是
Lucia: Hey, right outside our door...
Jake:看看时间先看这个
Jake: Check the time first, look at this.
Lucia: 那那些箱子是已经收拾过的吗
Lucia: Are those boxes already packed?
Alice:搅好了吗
Shure: 浇好了
Shure: It's done.
Shure: 有点稀了
Shure: It's a bit thin.
Shure: 但是问题不大
Shure: But it's not a big problem.
爱丝丽：没事
Lucia: 啊那也行
Lucia: Ah, that's fine then.
Alice:放盐了吗
Alice: Did you add salt?
Katrina: 你你吃麻酱还是吃什么酱
Katrina: Do you prefer sesame paste or something else?
Shure: 放盐盐多了
Shure: Added salt, too much salt.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Alice:我只吃麻酱
Alice: I only eat sesame paste.
Alice:我不吃油碟吃不了
Alice: I can't handle oil dips.
Shure: 放了放盐了
Shure: Added salt, added salt.
Alice:你吃油碟还是什么
Katrina: 油碟醋
Katrina: Oil dip with vinegar.
Shure: 其实本来是应该加酱油
Shure: Actually, it should have soy sauce.
Alice:但是我们买油碟了吗
Alice: Did Alfo buy oil dips?
Katrina: 香菜
Katrina: Cilantro.
Katrina: 买了买了
Katrina: Bought it, bought it.
Shure: 或者生抽来调这个咸味
Shure: Or light soy sauce to adjust the saltiness.
Katrina: 对对对
Katrina: Right, right, right.
Alice:是，味极鲜那种可以直接
Katrina: 昨天没买酱油
Katrina: Didn't buy soy sauce yesterday.
Shure: 差不多就这样
Shure: That's about it.
Katrina: 是吧无所谓吧
Katrina: Right? It doesn't really matter.
Alice:无所谓
Alice: Doesn't matter.
Katrina: 都能吃但我不吃麻酱
Katrina: I can eat anything but I don't like sesame paste.
Shure: 你们怎么私闯我的房间呢
Shure: How did you guys break into my room?
Katrina: 够不够
Katrina: Is it enough?
Katrina: go go
Katrina: Go, go.
Jake:暗中
Jake: In secret.
Lucia: 哎又校准一次
Lucia: Oh, calibrate it again.
Jake:你没电了
Jake: Your battery is dead.
Jake:不亮了
Jake: It's not lighting up.
Jake:那是怎么回事
Jake: What's going on?
Katrina: 走不走走不走
Katrina: Are we going or not?
Jake:看看你的电
Jake: Check your battery.
Katrina: 要走赶紧走
Katrina: If we're going, let's go quickly.
Jake:还是他会这有电
Jake: Or maybe it still has power.
Jake:插上的
Jake: It's plugged in.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Okay, okay.
Katrina: 很艺术你看那画家的感觉走不走
Katrina: Very artistic, you see, it feels like a painter. Are we going?
Shure: 谢
Shure: Thanks.
Choiszt: 霓虹几乌鸡豆
Choiszt: Neon chicken beans.
Jake:按一下才能充
Jake: You have to press it to charge.
Shure: 走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Jake:所以
Jake: So...
Katrina: 溜一圈回来
Katrina: Take a walk and come back.
Katrina: 今天还没出去透气
Katrina: Haven't gone out for fresh air today.
Shure: 走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Jake:所以你要开一下
Jake: So you need to turn it on.
Shure: 咱去走
Shure: Let's go.
Jake:还得再浇水
Jake: Still need to water it again.
Shure: 哪有人上厕所
Shure: Is there anyone in the bathroom?
Katrina: 不知道啊
Katrina: No idea.
Lucia: 虽然很难想
Lucia: Although it's hard to imagine.
Lucia: 不过我觉得我有一个大概的计划了
Lucia: But I think I have a rough plan.
Alice:你选了几呀
Alice: Which ones did you pick?
Lucia: 我就是我计划里的
Lucia: The ones in my plan.
Lucia: 现在有一二三四五个
Lucia: Now there are one, two, three, four, five of them.
Lucia: 五个东西就是可以用来装饰一下的
Lucia: These five things can be used for decoration.
Lucia: 不过还没下单
Lucia: But I haven't ordered them yet.
Alice:有点少我
Alice: Seems a bit few.
Lucia: 因为我还没想好然后可能
Lucia: Because I'm still thinking, and maybe...
Lucia: 可能再加一点贴纸或者之类的东西
Lucia: Maybe we can add some stickers or something like that.
Alice:我可能就四四哎我也差不多好像
Alice: I think I'm at four-four, I guess I'm almost there too.
Jake:没关系你一会再拍吧
Jake: It's okay, you can shoot it later.
Alice:一二三四四五个差不多
Lucia: 如果我们有预算
Lucia: If we have the budget,
Lucia: 我是不是可以买个娃娃
Lucia: can I buy a doll?
Lucia: 把它当成装饰
Lucia: Use it as decoration.
Lucia: 最后再带回去
Lucia: And take it back at the end.
Alice: 可以
Alice: Sure.
Lucia: 就是符合我的那个风格的
Lucia: It just matches my style.
Alice:你设计怎么样了
Tasha: 恩
Alice:差不多了
Tasha: 恩，预备买一些东西
Lucia: 抄作业哈哈哈
Lucia: Copying homework, haha.
Alice:啊我也喜欢地毯
Alice: Ah, I like carpets too.
Lucia: 啊哎
Lucia: Oh, hey.
Lucia: 我没有放地毯
Lucia: I didn't use a carpet.
Lucia: 不过我因为我那个房间进去那个空间
Lucia: But because the space in my room...
Lucia: 它是有一个那
Lucia: There's something...
Lucia: 样的然后再进去我觉得不是很好选
Lucia: Like that, then going in, I think it's hard to choose.
Alice:的嗯对
Alice: Yeah, right.
Lucia: 地毯我就没选
Lucia: So I didn't choose a carpet.
Lucia: 哦不过咱俩户型是一样的应该
Lucia: Oh, but our layouts should be the same.
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh.
Lucia: 我想搞一个
Lucia: I want to make one...
Alice:那我们现在正在录的话
Alice: If we're recording now,
Alice:应该可以说了吧
Alice: we can probably talk about it, right?
Lucia: 对可以说了吧
Lucia: Yeah, we can talk about it now.
Lucia: 咱不是专门把这个留着
Lucia: Didn't we save this especially for...
Alice:因为对
Alice: Yeah, because...
Lucia: 但是微微的还没打开
Lucia: But Tasha hasn't opened it yet.
Lucia: 应该没关系
Lucia: It should be fine.
Lucia: 我想弄一个
Lucia: I want to make one...
Lucia: 就是那种毛毡照片墙
Lucia: Like a felt photo wall.
Lucia: 就可以拿图钉往上戳照片的那个
Lucia: So you can pin photos on it with thumbtacks.
Lucia: 然后我看他好像买那个照片墙
Lucia: And I saw that if you buy the photo wall,
Lucia: 就会送美文纸
Lucia: it comes with aesthetic paper.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Lucia: 我就可以直接贴在墙上
Lucia: I can just stick it on the wall.
Alice:那你想做什么风格呢大概
Alice: What style do you want to go for?
Lucia: 其实我想做蓝色系
Lucia: Actually, I want to do a blue theme.
Alice:我昨天想过
Alice: I thought about it yesterday.
Alice:但是
Alice: But
Alice:我就是没有找到我喜欢的那个蓝色
Alice: I just couldn't find the blue I liked.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Alice:然后我就换了换成
Alice: So I switched it to
Alice:森林的那种感觉
Alice: A forest kind of feel.
Lucia: 啊我现在
Lucia: Ah, now I
Alice:嗯绿色的其实我不是很喜欢绿色
Alice: Hmm, green... actually, I don't really like green.
Lucia: 我现在
Lucia: Now I
Lucia: 我现在想法可能是做一点偏地中海
Lucia: Now I’m thinking about doing something more Mediterranean.
Alice:海洋
Alice: Ocean
Lucia: 对对对对那种风格
Lucia: Yes, yes, that kind of style.
Lucia: 所以我想再买一个
Lucia: So I want to buy another
Lucia: 再买一张渔网
Lucia: Another fishing net.
Lucia: 然后咱们把它挂一下
Lucia: And then we’ll hang it up.
Lucia: 我刚就是在想怎样挂会比较好看
Lucia: I was just thinking about how to hang it to look nice.
Alice:那个渔网
Alice: That fishing net
Alice:挂的话你是不是可以买点什么水母啊
Alice: When you hang it, maybe you can buy some jellyfish
Alice:或者贝壳那种元素在上面
Alice: Or shell elements to decorate it.
Lucia: 对我也是在想这个
Lucia: Yes, I was thinking the same.
Lucia: 就把它点缀一下
Lucia: Just to decorate it a bit.
Lucia: 但我还在想怎么挂
Lucia: But I'm still thinking about how to hang it.
Lucia: 就要不然把它直接挂在照片墙上
Lucia: Maybe just hang it directly on the photo wall.
Lucia: 然后再然后再在那个渔网上面戳照片
Lucia: And then pin photos on the fishing net.
Alice:我昨天瘦了一圈
Alice: I lost some weight yesterday.
Lucia: 但我好像没
Lucia: But I think
Lucia: 我觉得现在好像不太来得及打印照片
Lucia: I think it's too late to print photos now.
Lucia: 我要不要买几张图算了
Lucia: Should I just buy some pictures?
Lucia: 可能也很便宜买几张明信片
Lucia: It might be cheap to buy some postcards.
Alice:昨天想了很多的
Alice: I thought a lot yesterday.
Alice:呃星星就水星海母贝壳用海洋元素
Alice: Uh, stars, Mercury, jellyfish, shells, using ocean elements.
Alice:然后发现就没有喜欢的那种蓝色
Alice: But then I couldn't find the blue I liked.
Alice:我就我就换了
Alice: So I switched it.
Alice:你看这个是我自己的那个小海星
Alice: Look, this is my little starfish.
Alice:我就真的很喜欢海洋
Alice: I really love the ocean.
Lucia: 好好看哇好好看
Lucia: It's so pretty, so pretty.
Lucia: 这是你自己自己设计的吗
Lucia: Did you design this yourself?
Lucia: 自己做的啊
Lucia: You made it yourself?
Lucia: 好看耶
Lucia: It looks great.
Lucia: 我想想我们学校之前有一个课
Lucia: I remember our school had a class
Alice:还行
Lucia: 就他有点像电工实习
Lucia: It was kind of like electrical practice.
Alice:恩
Lucia: 但不完全一样
Lucia: But it's not exactly the same.
Lucia: 就是也会自己做节制
Lucia: I mean, you also have to control yourself.
Lucia: 对然后我当时做的也是一个星星
Lucia: Yeah, and back then I made a star too.
Lucia: 不过不是
Lucia: But it wasn't...
Jake:卢亚来帮帮个忙帮个忙
Jake: Lua, come help me out, help me out.
Lucia: 海星啊怎么了
Lucia: Starfish, what's wrong?
Lucia: what's wrong
Lucia: What's wrong?
Jake:我一不小心按到了这个电源键
Jake: I accidentally pressed the power button.
Jake:我要松的话我就凉了
Jake: If I let go, I'm done for.
Jake:所以
Jake: So...
Lucia: 所以
Lucia: So...
Jake:所以你要帮我把所有硬盘都退出去
Jake: So you need to help me eject all the hard drives.
Lucia: 怎么退
Lucia: How do I do that?
Jake:就是就是那个退出退出
Jake: Just, just eject them.
Lucia: 天呐不是您真的情绪好稳定
Lucia: Oh my god, you are really calm.
Alice:天呐哪个是我的水啊
Alice: Oh my god, which one is my water?
Jake:就是地雷知道吧
Jake: It's like a minefield, you know?
Lucia: 我我我怎样怎样
Lucia: I, I, what, what do I do?
Alice:哦，这个不是我的水，我没有弄这个
Alice:那说明这个是我的
Alice:是吗，是吗
Lucia: 我帮你挪一下可以吗
Lucia: Can I move it for you?
Alice:我我我
Tasha: 天哪
Tasha: Oh my god.
Lucia: 最下下面的这个就是退出号
Lucia: The bottom one is the eject button.
Tasha: 重新
Tasha: Reset.
Alice:是我的吧，应该是
Alice:喝掉都
Lucia: 他得退一会吗不
Lucia: Does it take a while? No.
Jake:啊你摁一下
Jake: Ah, just press it.
Alice:怎么了
Alice: What's wrong?
Tasha: 我说重新拿一瓶吧能能
Tasha: I said just get a new bottle, can you?
Jake:或者你摁
Jake: Or you press...
Alice:桌上只有两瓶
Alice: There are only two bottles on the table.
Alice:应该就是我放的那一瓶
Alice: It should be the one I put there.
Lucia: 弹出失败
Lucia: Eject failed.
Alice:就这样吧
Alice:你在干什么
Lucia: 你看哪个电脑比较方便
Lucia: Which computer is more convenient?
Lucia: 我先操作那个电脑
Lucia: I'll start with that one.
Lucia: 然后接下来的我就可以照本宣科了
Lucia: Then I can follow the routine for the rest.
Jake:好你看我
Jake: Okay, watch me.
Jake:啊就是就是这个
Jake: Ah, it's, it's this one.
Lucia: 啊原来不是统一的嗯
Lucia: Ah, so it's not standardized, hmm.
Alice:怎么
Tasha: 没事干
Tasha: Nothing to do.
Alice:叹气
Alice: Sigh.
Lucia: 我要我要给他们讲这个故事
Lucia: I, I want to tell them this story.
Jake:这个故事确实挺好讲
Jake: This story is really worth telling.
Alice:欣赏我们的花吧
Alice: Appreciate our flowers.
Alice:你看我们的就很有层次
Alice: Look at ours, it's very layered.
Alice:但是你这个就是一只
Alice: But yours is just one.
Alice:上面就好几个头
Alice: And it has several heads on top.
Alice:就这种高度
Alice: At this height.
Alice:这个高度是没办法变的
Alice: This height can't be changed.
Alice:我好像单针的比较多
Alice: I seem to have more single needles.
Alice:外边纸箱吗
Alice: Are those cardboard boxes outside?
Alice:要不先留一下
Alice: How about we keep them for now?
Alice:哦谢谢阿姨
Alice: Oh, thank you, auntie.
Alice: 呃好的
Alice: Uh, okay.
Tasha: 喂
Tasha: Hello.
Tasha: 拿快递是吗
Tasha: Are you picking up a package?
Tasha: 我想我问一下
Tasha: I think I'll ask.
Lucia: 此电脑
Lucia: This computer.
Tasha: 今天也不去拿快递是吗
Tasha: Not picking up the package today either?
Jake:什么快递
Jake: What package?
Tasha: 啊嗯没有人拿要不下次再拿吧
Tasha: Ah, well, no one is picking it up, maybe we should get it next time.
Jake:你要去拿快递吗
Jake: Are you going to get the package?
Jake:呃你说今天有些快递到了
Jake: Uh, you said some packages arrived today.
Tasha: 我上午的时候好像就说有
Tasha: I think I said there were some this morning.
Tasha: 他跟我说他在
Tasha: He told me he is here.
Tasha: 他说他今天现在在
Tasha: He said he is here today now.
Tasha: 嗯但其实不是很重要的快递
Tasha: Yeah, but it's not a very important package.
Tasha: 应该吧我不知道9707
Tasha: I guess, I don't know.
Tasha: 那他是房东拿来送来了吗
Tasha: Did the landlord bring it over?
Jake:呃是的是的
Jake: Uh, yes, yes.
Jake:111707
Jake: 111707
Tasha: 9707
Tasha: 喂你好
Tasha: Hello, hi.
Tasha: 啊房东等会说去拿然后帮我们送过来
Tasha: Ah, the landlord said he would pick it up and bring it to us.
Lucia: 了这个没有360就直接弹出呗
Lucia: This one doesn't have 360, it just pops up.
Jake:对对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Jake:早上的那个毫米波也是因为360转了
Jake: The millimeter wave thing in the morning was also because 360 turned.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈我觉得我比你要慌一些
Lucia: Hahaha, I think I'm more flustered than you.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 您怎么情绪这么稳定
Lucia: How are you so calm?
Lucia: 这个好像也没有360
Lucia: This one doesn't seem to have 360 either.
Lucia: 现在
Lucia: Now
Lucia: AI是不是收集到了一些很神奇的数据
Lucia: Has the AI collected some amazing data?
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Jake:是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes
Jake:现在知道怎么让人不关机
Jake: Now it knows how to keep people from shutting down
Lucia: 他现在他提示这个安全移除
Lucia: Now it's prompting for safe removal
Lucia: 这是多少
Lucia: How much is this?
Lucia: 六六 7个屏幕体验卡
Lucia: Six, six, 7 screen experience cards
Lucia: 这好像也没有360
Lucia: This doesn't seem to have 360 either
Lucia: 我觉得电脑是一个
Lucia: I think the computer is one
Lucia: 经常莫名其妙就自己抽分的玩意
Lucia: That often randomly messes up
Lucia: 就是也可能因为我不是学这个的啊
Lucia: Maybe because I'm not an expert in this
Lucia: 但总之我经常这么觉得
Lucia: But I often feel this way
Lucia: 啊你你现在啊
Lucia: Ah, you, you now, ah
Lucia: 啊那行有什么想要的角度吗
Lucia: Ah, okay, do you have a preferred angle?
Lucia: 你哪个角度比较比较觉
Lucia: Which angle do you think looks best?
Lucia: 自己觉得比较好看的可以
Lucia: The one you think looks good
Lucia: 那要不看镜头
Lucia: Or look at the camera?
Lucia: 一会发您
Lucia: I'll send it to you later
Jake:your time都可以啊
Jake: Your time is fine
Lucia: 还是发群里
Lucia: Or send it to the group?
Lucia: 这个这个是有360的
Lucia: This one has 360
Jake:对右下角有一个这个
Jake: Yes, there's one at the bottom right
Lucia: 三角那个吗这个
Lucia: The triangle one? This one?
Jake:对然后右键关掉它
Jake: Yes, then right-click to close it
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:要不然我就在这盯着盯到各位回家
Jake: Otherwise, I'll just keep watching until everyone goes home
Lucia: 等到大家回来
Lucia: Until everyone comes back
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes
Lucia: 然后再再那个用Windows自带的那个
Lucia: Then use the built-in Windows one again
Lucia: 这外面是直升机吗
Lucia: Is that a helicopter outside?
Lucia: 这个声音
Lucia: That sound
Lucia: 哦哦sorry
Lucia: Oh, oh, sorry
Lucia: 听着真的很像直升机
Lucia: It really sounds like a helicopter
Lucia: 但这个地方有什么必要
Lucia: But why would there be one here?
Jake:或者是飞机
Jake: Or an airplane
Lucia: 这是l e
Lucia: This is LE
Lucia: 这个东西不用管他吗
Lucia: Should we ignore this?
Lucia: 就您这还有一个正在备份的
Lucia: There's also a backup in progress here
Jake:这个宾馆我我已经火了
Jake: This hotel, I'm already famous
Katrina: 咬你了
Katrina: Bit you.
Lucia: 哈哈哈不用谢
Lucia: Hahaha, no need to thank me.
Lucia: 我们中午吃饭
Lucia: We had lunch.
Lucia: 你还没上来的时候
Lucia: When you hadn't come up yet.
Lucia: 大家其实在讨论你是不是一个AI
Lucia: Everyone was actually discussing if you were an AI.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈因为情绪过于稳定
Lucia: Haha, because your emotions are too stable.
Jake:不好是吧
Jake: Not good, right?
Jake:麻了
Jake: Numb.
Lucia: 大家easy不会争吵看看又什么灵感
Lucia: Everyone, take it easy, no arguing, let's see if there's any inspiration.
Alice:买个桌布
Lucia: 这个桌布好看啊
Alice:恩
Lucia: 我决定抄一下
Lucia: I decided to copy it.
Lucia: 不过改一个颜色
Lucia: But change a color.
Lucia: 没有开玩笑开玩笑
Lucia: Just kidding, just kidding.
Alice:这个还行
Alice: This is okay.
Alice:但不是我想要的那种颜色
Alice: But it's not the color I want.
Alice:但可以先加进去
Alice: But we can add it first.
Alice:然后慢慢删
Alice: Then slowly remove it.
Lucia: 我觉得我现在那几个装饰
Lucia: I think my current decorations.
Lucia: 都还是墙面的装饰
Lucia: Are still wall decorations.
Lucia: 没有什么桌子上的
Lucia: Nothing for the table.
Lucia: 因为我那个房间里面没有
Lucia: Because there's no table in my room.
Lucia: 没有桌子
Lucia: No table.
Lucia: 他只有一个小架子
Lucia: There's only a small shelf.
Lucia: 你那里面有桌子吗
Lucia: Do you have a table in yours?
Alice:啊啊你可以去看
Alice: Ah, you can go check.
Lucia: 呃可能会扫到
Lucia: Uh, might sweep it.
Alice:无所谓我收拾过了哈哈哈
Alice: Doesn't matter, I cleaned up, hahaha.
Lucia: 啊那我看过了
Lucia: Ah, then I checked.
Lucia: 啊那我看一眼
Lucia: Ah, then I'll take a look.
Alice:你看我我那有个桌子上上面有个灯
Alice: See, I have a table with a lamp on it.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 哦哎
Lucia: Oh, hey.
Lucia: 那你这个很好看
Lucia: This looks nice.
Lucia: 我那里面只有一个架子
Lucia: I only have a shelf in mine.
Lucia: 就是像这种置物布局是一样的
Lucia: The layout is the same as this storage arrangement.
Alice:间不是一样的吗
Lucia: 但是就是它家具没有桌子
Lucia: But there's no table in the furniture.
Lucia: 它只有一个置物架
Lucia: Only a storage rack.
Lucia: 所以
Lucia: So.
Lucia: 我就想给那个置物架上再放一个
Lucia: I want to put something on that rack.
Lucia: 那种小小的收纳
Lucia: Those small storage
Lucia: 收纳箱那种
Lucia: Storage boxes
Lucia: 让它整齐一些
Lucia: To make things tidy
Alice:可以的
Lucia: 啊这个小灯挺好看的
Lucia: Ah, this small lamp is quite pretty
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Lucia: 我说那个小灯挺好看的
Lucia: I said that small lamp is quite pretty
Alice:你没有灯吗
Alice: Don't you have a lamp?
Lucia: 我没有
Lucia: I don't
Alice:你只有上面的灯吗对
Alice: You only have the ceiling light, right?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right
Lucia: 是不是很amazing哈
Lucia: Isn't it amazing, huh
Alice:我以为我们是等比例复制粘贴
Alice: I thought we were copying and pasting proportionally
Lucia: 哈我们的房型是一样
Lucia: Ha, our room layouts are the same
Lucia: 但是里面的东西不太一样
Lucia: But the stuff inside is different
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Lucia: 搞一个蓝色的什么布
Lucia: Get some blue fabric
Lucia: 把床铺一铺好
Lucia: To cover the bed nicely
Alice: 买个杯垫
Alice: Buy a coaster
Alice:什么材料包啊
Alice: What material kit?
Alice:材料包我得勾到什么时候去
Alice: How long will it take me to crochet the material kit?
Lucia: 啊我知道了
Lucia: Ah, I know
Lucia: 我可以买一个宜家鲨鱼
Lucia: I can buy an IKEA shark
Lucia: 因为我是地中海风
Lucia: Because I have a Mediterranean style
Alice:是的
Alice: Yes
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Lucia: son of whore and Scotsman
Lucia: Son of whore and Scotsman
Lucia: 为什么一到这首歌声音突然变的这么小
Lucia: Why does the sound suddenly get so low when this song comes on?
Alice: 可以调吗
Alice: Can you adjust it?
Lucia: 好像不可以
Lucia: Seems like I can't
Lucia: 因为这个电脑有锁啊
Lucia: Because this computer has a lock
Lucia: 但我可以不同不打开他的锁
Lucia: But I can adjust the volume without unlocking it
Lucia: 光调音量
Lucia: Just the volume
Alice:这个是算你的吗
Alice: Is this yours?
Alice:他是编织贝壳
Alice: It's a woven shell
Katrina: 但是你要看
Katrina: But you have to see
Alice:有海滩的风格
Alice: It has a beach style
Lucia: 哎哦这个好好看哎
Lucia: Hey, this looks really nice
Alice:可以搜用贝壳什么的编织杯垫
Alice: You can search for coasters woven from shells
Lucia: 这是杯垫是吗
Lucia: Is this a coaster?
Lucia: 我搜我搜搜看有没有类似的
Lucia: I'll search, search to see if there's anything similar
Lucia: 虽然我可能
Lucia: Although I might
Lucia: 我那个房间里面应该放不了
Lucia: My room probably can't fit it
Lucia: 杯垫可以找找类似的其他的装饰
Lucia: We can look for similar coasters or other decorations
Shure: 怎么突然又多了几个碗啊
Shure: How come there are suddenly more bowls?
Alice:恩？
Lucia: 可能是桌上刚收过去的
Lucia: Maybe they were just cleared from the table
Lucia: 这剩的这个
Lucia: This leftover one
Lucia: 反正碗都要洗了
Lucia: Anyway, all the bowls need to be washed
Lucia: 要不把它倒了吧
Lucia: Why don't we just throw it out?
Shure: 好的
Shure: Okay
Shure: 早上是蘸白糖吃的吗
Shure: Did we dip it in sugar this morning?
Lucia: 对哎呦妈呀
Lucia: Yes, oh my
Lucia: 这个充电线怎么又开了是的
Lucia: Why is this charging cable acting up again
Lucia: 我擦一下手
Lucia: Let me wipe my hands
Lucia: 把这再带上
Lucia: And put this back on
Katrina: 这也得买最白的
Katrina: This has to be the whitest
Shure: 加了点但加了不多
Shure: I added some, but not much
Shure: 我不知道多少
Shure: I don't know how much
Shure: 那些那些没有
Shure: Those, those didn't have
Shure: 腐乳什么的没有
Shure: No fermented tofu or anything
Shure: 老北京二八酱是吧
Shure: It's the old Beijing 28 sauce, right?
Shure: 主要怕有人不吃什么的
Shure: Mainly worried someone wouldn't eat it
Shure: 美团现在送一点是来得及的
Shure: Meituan can still deliver a bit now
Shure: 你美团点一下
Shure: You can order on Meituan
Shure: 要不
Shure: Or
Shure: 腐乳和韭菜花这俩
Shure: Fermented tofu and chive flower sauce
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Shure: 点吗
Shure: Order?
Lucia: 3525
Lucia: 25大概有这么宽
Lucia: 25 is about this wide
Lucia: 好像也差不多了
Lucia: Seems about right
Jake:不回来了吗
Jake: Not coming back?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Jake:雨轩也没回来哈
Jake: Yuxuan didn't come back either
Jake:哈哈哈伤心哈哈哈
Jake: Haha so sad haha
Shure: 你好
Shure: Hello
Shure: 有没有一点人服感
Shure: Do you feel any human touch?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Shure: 人服感
Shure: Human touch
Shure: 就是
Shure: Just
Shure: 人肤感就是
Shure: Human skin touch, like
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: 人人机感和人肤感对
Shure: The machine sense and human touch, right?
Jake:学到一些很难翻译的东西
Jake: I learned some things that are hard to translate.
Shure: 这怎么
Shure: How do you...
Shure: host husband
Shure: Host husband.
Shure: style感feeling yeah
Shure: Style feeling, yeah.
Shure: feeling of host husband
Shure: Feeling of host husband.
Shure: 我去楼上吃饭一会
Shure: I'm going upstairs to eat for a bit.
Jake:对去布置布置
Jake: Yeah, go set things up a bit.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Jake:我们拖桌子去吧
Jake: Let's move the table.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Sure.
Alice:为啥一看淘宝就困
Alice: Why do I always get sleepy when I look at Taobao?
Lucia: 物业
Lucia: Property management.
Alice:是个重复性的工作
Alice: It's a repetitive task.
Alice:我一看我就犯困
Alice: I get sleepy just looking at it.
Lucia: 我去把这个凳子再给他们搬上去
Lucia: I'll go move that chair upstairs for them.
Lucia: 要不然上面凳子就不够了
Lucia: Otherwise, there won't be enough chairs upstairs.
Shure: 我可以上楼了
Shure: Can I go upstairs now?
Shure: 带着一把凳子
Shure: Taking a chair with me.
Alice: 哦，好的
Alice: 带个板凳是吗
Alice: Taking a stool, right?
Shure: 慢得和你走到3的
Shure: Slowly, we'll get to the third floor together.
Lucia: 现在都上去吗
Lucia: Are we all going up now?
Tasha: 毛都说的上去
Tasha: Mao said to go up.
Jake:都来了
Jake: Everyone's here.
Alice:凳子够吗 123
Alice: Are there enough chairs? 1, 2, 3.
Jake:go
Jake: Go.
Alice:哎呦我的妈呀
Alice: Oh my gosh.
Alice:吓我一跳
Alice: You scared me!
Alice:怎么还滑了呢
Tasha: 嗯没有人
Tasha: Hmm, no one's here.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Shure: 来吧我们摆锅摆菜准备开始
Shure: Come on, let's set up the pots and dishes, get ready to start.
Alice:厕所有人吗
Alice: Is someone in the bathroom?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
Shure: 没有吧
Shure: I don't think so.
Tasha: 应该没有吧
Tasha: Probably not.
Shure: 没有咱们都在
Shure: No, we're all here.
Shure: 然后那个那谁还在咖啡厅
Shure: And that person is still in the cafe.
Shure: 其他都回来了
Shure: Everyone else is back.
Alice:恩，好，上趟厕所
Alice:开个门吧
Tasha: 上面怎么这么冷
Tasha: Why is it so cold up here?
Lucia: 因为之前空调一直开着
Lucia: Because the air conditioner was on earlier.
Shure: 刚开空调然后现在关了
Shure: It was just turned on and now it's off.
Alice:拜拜，我去上个厕所
Shure: 这锁是坏的
Shure: This lock is broken.
Shure: 但是我们不会进的
Shure: But we won't go in.
Lucia: 那个锁是坏的
Lucia: That lock is broken.
Lucia: 这锁还是好的
Lucia: This lock is still good.
Lucia: 左边这锁好
Lucia: The lock on the left is good.
Lucia: 所以大家在这里上洗手间的时候
Lucia: So when everyone uses the bathroom here,
Lucia: 要养成先敲门的习惯
Lucia: you should get into the habit of knocking first.
Shure: 真的没人
Shure: There's really no one.
Shure: 没有
Shure: No one.
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh man.
Shure: 不至于神精兮兮
Lucia: 哦这有牛奶锅
Lucia: Oh, there's a milk pot here.
Lucia: 这是他这带的
Lucia: Did he bring this?
Lucia: 还是咱们的呀
Lucia: Or is it ours?
Shure: 我的咖啡壶
Shure: It's my coffee pot.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia: 当我没说哈哈哈
Lucia: Pretend I didn't say anything, haha.
Shure: 嗯可以
Shure: Hmm, okay.
Lucia: 啊太饿了
Lucia: Ah, I'm so hungry.
Tasha: 我也好饿呀
Tasha: I'm so hungry too.
Lucia: 让我看看这有什么吃的
Lucia: Let me see what's there to eat.
Tasha: 我们把绿豆饼吃了吧
Tasha: Let's eat the mung bean cakes.
Lucia: 我支持我支持
Lucia: I support that, I support.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Lucia: 哈哈那我们下去睡
Lucia: Haha, then let's go downstairs and sleep.
Tasha: 好啊
Tasha: Okay.
Lucia: 还是在这
Lucia: Or stay here.
Tasha: 要不要拿上来吃
Tasha: Should we bring it up to eat?
Lucia: 拿上来也行
Lucia: Bringing it up is fine too.
Lucia: 那会就放这个冰箱里行
Lucia: Then we can just put it in this fridge.
Tasha: 行啊哈哈好饿呀
Tasha: Okay, haha, I'm so hungry.
Lucia: 哈哈哈可以可以
Lucia: Hahaha, alright, alright.
Shure: 桌子没擦
Shure: The table isn't wiped.
Shure: 所以可能有点脏
Shure: So it might be a bit dirty.
Tasha:忘了擦
Tasha: Forgot to wipe it.
Shure: 得稍微擦一下
Shure: We need to wipe it a bit.
Lucia: 啊就是火锅用的东西
Lucia: Ah, it's just things for hotpot.
Lucia: 基本上可以都拿上去
Lucia: 咕嘟咕嘟嘟嘟嘟
Lucia: Glug glug glug glug glug.
Lucia: 啊要命
Lucia: Oh, that's a killer.
Tasha: 要不要把锅拿上去
Tasha: Should we take the pot up?
Tasha: 哎有两个鸳鸯锅
Tasha: Hey, there are two divided pots.
Lucia: 嗯
Tasha: 楼上有一个卡式炉
Tasha: There's a portable stove upstairs.
Tasha: 再拿一个电磁炉就行
Tasha: We just need to bring an induction cooker.
Shure: 好的
Shure: Got it.
Tasha: 嘿
Tasha: Hey.
Tasha: 在这里
Tasha: Over here.
Shure: 插排拿过来
Shure: Bring the power strip over.
Shure: 插排不够长吧
Shure: The power strip isn't long enough, right?
Shure: 够吗
Shure: Is it enough?
Shure: 插排不够长
Shure: The power strip isn't long enough.
Shure: 再接个插排
Shure: Connect another power strip.
Jake:打牌不够长
Jake: The deck isn't long enough.
Jake:再接呗再接一个
Jake: Connect another one.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Shure: 排接排
Shure: Strip to strip.